pennsylvania the two teams fighting it
out this weekend as they do once every
four years the eagles at the pittsburgh
steelers you know the steelers were not
dominant in any of their first three
games peter and they didn't beat teams
that have done really all that much this
year they they beat the giants who are
winless they beat the broncos who have
one win over a winless jets team
they beat the texans who are now 0 and 4
and have fired their coach slash gm
how are the steelers really going to
look i'm curious about this especially
with an unscheduled buy that has left
some of the players seemingly a little
salty about what happened last week
yeah mike
you know what is strange about the
steelers the steelers came back this
year with their pretty much their full
compliment
you know
with with ben roethlisberger back
with uh juju smith schuster and some
really good young receivers
i mean but they've been good on offense
but they haven't been explosive
i mean if you were to tell me right now
name me one team i bet there's probably
what eight teams in the nfl so far this
year
that haven't scored in the 30s yet this
year
if you had told me the pittsburgh
steelers
with roethlisberger looking like classic
big ben health-wise
we're going to be one of those teams
that you know their highest point totals
so far is 28. uh it just sounds we when
everybody else is scoring at a record
clip it just sounds weird to me so i
really like the steelers i think the
steelers have a chance
to be there at the end and to fight and
scratch and claw the ravens for the
division title which was kind of
far-fetched a month ago
but i really like their defense and i
like their defense because it doesn't
rely on one
weapon but dupreeh the huge star in the
first week against the giants since then
clearly
you know
hayward and watt have both been at times
dominant especially tj watt
so
i really like the steelers to get better
as the year goes on
hopefully for them okay
they get 16 games out of big ben because
if they don't then they're just a member
of the pack
and and i i wonder
how much they benefited from the
unscheduled buy to the extent that they
practiced all week it's kind of like a
little reconvening of training camp
right now they didn't know they were
preparing for the titans but still
you're practicing you're in your routine
you're getting more reps in for a team
that didn't have preseason games for a
team that's working ben roethlisberger
back into the mix and that really hasn't
clicked i mean they could have lost to
the giants they could have lost to the
broncos they could have lost to the
texans they have not been that team that
we thought they'd be from the standpoint
of winning games easily against bad
teams and let's face it they faced three
bad teams this is their opportunity to
really show that they can dominate
because the eagles clearly not one of
the better teams in the nfl they're
feeling good about themselves after
beating the 49ers on sunday night but
you know that offense for pittsburgh we
need to see more and defensively peter
let's flip it over to the eagles now
carson wentz running a lot this year
carson wentz throwing caution to the
wind the one team you don't want to do
that against is the pittsburgh steelers
because they will come and they will get
you
you know here's the thing about the
steelers too
you know if you look at their schedule
who would have ever thought in the first
six weeks of the season that their
toughest game would be the cleveland
browns but that's who they face next
week they have a really really
interesting stretch after they play
philly cleveland tennessee baltimore you
know and and that to me is really going
to tell the tale of this team by the
midpoint of this season we're going to
know everything we need to know about
the steelers then it's going to be all
about ben roethlisberger's health
yeah i agree with you completely and
isn't it odd to think that the
the steelers and the browns is a big
game i mean steelers fans are accustomed
it's going to be
decades
decades of peering down their noses
at the browns but when you look at the
all-time series
76-59-1
now it goes back years it goes back
years before the steelers were ever any
good i'm i'm guessing over the past 50
years
the winds have favored the steelers but
the steelers fans just look at the
browns it's just it's a tune-up game man
we you know and now
now
twice this year they're going to have to
be dealing with a browns team that that
could beat them both in pittsburgh
and in cleveland if it comes down to it
so important game this weekend for the
steelers to get back on the field get on
the right track and get a win that isn't
you know one score
feels like it could have gone either way
because they're going to be playing some
good teams soon starting with and it's
hard to articulate these words the very
good cleveland browns all right speaking
of the browns three in one
hosting the cults three in one and the
cults are very good the cults playing
defense arguably better than anyone else
i watched that colts bears game how they
stymied the chicago offense the entire
game they had three points until the
final minute chicago did
do we i look i think both teams can make
the playoffs do you see either of these
teams
as a team that could go toe to toe with
the best teams in the conference
i don't yet but
you know mike uh it's october 9th you're
not the same team
uh
on december 9th as you are on october
9th so you know you develop your team
phillip rivers developing a rapport with
a bunch of new guys that until
you know two months ago he never played
with before
so and never practiced with before quite
honestly so
you know let's see how that develops and
you've noticed one thing about the colts
that i think is really interesting
so
chris ballard you know as a as a roster
builder
is always going to flood his roster
with defensive lineman it's his position
andy reid loves the offensive lineman
chris ballard loves the defensive
lineman and i think when you see
deforest buckner still sort of getting
used to this scheme and you see matt
eberflus the defensive coordinator
getting used to
how to plug people in to new spots
all sort of centered around the orbit
same way the seahawks center around
bobby wagner the indianapolis colts
their orbit revolves around obviously
darius leonard they've had a great start
in particular you know what stat right
there that is really really good is the
third down percentage because today in
today's football where everything is
explosive and the third down percentage
is somewhere in the mid 40s to have a
third down percentage with your team
less than one in three is phenomenal
matt eberthlus right now mike is really
uh putting out his resume for everybody
to see so don't necessarily just hand
out all these head coaching jobs after
this season and don't include matt
eberflus on your interview list
speaking of darius leonard the heart and
soul of that defense he did not practice
wednesday or thursday with a groin
injury he said yesterday he can play
even if he doesn't practice at all this
week that may be a signal we're not
going to see him practice today and he
probably ends up with that questionable
label going into sunday they definitely
need him or it becomes a lot harder to
win and the browns flipping it around
i'm still amazed that
nick chubb had 43 yards rushing before
he injured his knee and the browns still
had 307 rushing yards and with the game
on the line
and four-minute offense
in operation
kevin stefanski knew i got to give a
dodo beckham jr and i expect we're going
to see more of that and stefanski said
after the game i'm challenging myself to
get the ball in his hands earlier and
they're going to need that if they want
to have a chance to beat the good teams
and now they've got two straight weeks
of good teams colts and steelers we'll
learn a lot about the browns over the
next two weekends peter
look you know what
what this occurred to me and i i had a
good conversation with stefanski after
the game sunday
i think one of the things that kevin
stefanski has done
is he has looked at his roster mic
and he has said i think mentally he's
got it in his head that every week i am
getting the ball early or going to
attempt to get the ball early to odell
beckham jr now you notice mike he only
got seven touches in that game and you
say man they gotta give more more
touches but the difference is
he got touches early and he was still in
it late when he made that incredible run
around aldon smith uh and made that
50-yard touchdown run which probably was
like 98 yards that he actually ran
50 scrimmage yards though there's one
other point i would make about these
browns
when chubb goes out of the game what
happens do you see any drop off at all
no
mike
they put in a guy named ernest johnson a
free agent from immokalee florida
undrafted free agent from south florida
immokalee florida if that sounds
familiar that's edgar in james's
hometown
and he comes in 13 carries 95 yards and
the reason why i bring him up
is that i think one of the things
that this team has done going back
honestly uh not just andrew berry the
current gm but they have been adding
quality depth players going back to john
dorsey they've been adding quality depth
players to this team that you're now
seeing
this is bearing fruit you lose chub
you put in johnson and you do not miss a
beat
yeah and it's a testament to what kevin
stefanski is doing it all comes down to
getting the hand getting the ball in the
hands of your best players and it
doesn't have to be difficult if you want
to get the ball in otto beckham jr's
hands you don't have to force it to him
30 yards down the field you can get him
screen pass you can do an end around you
can do the things they did just to get
get him in that spot where he's got the
ball and the other team has to try to
catch him and a lot of times the other
team is not successful all right raiders
and chiefs chiefs look flat
on monday night maybe that had something
to do with bill belichick in the
patriots defense
raiders come to town raiders have lost
two in a row after starting the season
2-0
is this a bounce back for the chiefs is
this going to be one of those the
raiders wish they hadn't shown up type
of games
um
mike i you know i wa i i think one of
the reasons why
um
i think
that
opinions get changed so much early in
the season
is that you just need to see a team play
a little bit more like i i how do you
not love the chiefs
you gotta love the chiefs they're
probably the best team in football okay
but
two times out of four games
they have just stumbled around on
offense
you know against the chargers they had
to go to overtime against a kid making
his first nfl start
and then against the patriots now espn's
graphic i thought was wonderful on
monday night when they said
that there have been three
first halfs in his career you know that
mahomes has been held in check i think
it was either he's been shut out or you
know he's had no touchdowns and all
three have come against uh the patriots
so
i kind of look at the chiefs and say i
want to see a little bit more
i want to see them sustain drives a
little bit more against defenses paul
gunther has done nothing this off season
i think except over and over look at the
kansas city chiefs this is our biggest
competitor we have got to find a way as
a raider defense to solve mahomes and
honestly mike who isn't doing that this
offseason so i think i really want to
see
patrick mahomes come out and dominate a
team
that has a chance to be pretty good
because two out of four games so far
this year they haven't dominated
and when you look at their schedule this
year it really sets up for them to have
a special season no matter how good they
are or aren't and maybe they don't get
really tested until the post season
they've got the week six game at buffalo
which is a real test obviously and one
of the great games of of the week and
great games of the year so far and and
it's a shame that we won't get to enjoy
it standing alone in prime time if it
bumps to sunday but you look at the
schedule beyond that broncos jets
panthers
raiders again they play the buccaneers
week 12 in tampa that's one that you
circle broncos dolphins saints in new
orleans just circle that one
out of the next 12 games
there's only three that you circle peter
and and the rest of them they should win
they should go
at 4-0
they should be 13-3
at the very minimum the question is what
do they do in those three games that we
would circle bills bucks and saints all
on the road
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports